when it comes to eSports we've learned
to expect that sometimes things can get
a bit awkward for the thousands of
attendants and millions watching around
the world are you yeah well thanks a lot
crimps I appreciate you coming out here
is a pleasure and of course up
I just wanted to say something real
quick
Nintendo World Championships I'm like
hey what's up hello
thomna please hash with my sisters and
my bros married to the scene I can never
let it go
name is de 1 you guess don't guess you
already know enough about me and I was
time to enjoy the show
with twitch there are emotes for
basically everything and since we're
talking about a medium where anyone with
a PC internet connection and webcam can
participate things sometimes get a
little out of hand to play with so much
confidence on the world stage
[Music]
[Applause]
when that happens when something is so
uncomfortable that it's funny we call it
cringe humor and a solitary icon has
emerged to become quite literally the
face of that humorous discomfort the
haha emo who is added to better twitch
TV a browser extension that enables
additional emos on Twitch in 2015 that
means that while anyone can type haha
you only see the emote if you have bttv
installed with haha you're not laughing
with someone you're laughing at someone
for about three months I thought it was
an actual laughing emote and I'm like
wow they're putting it again I'm gonna
keep telling these jokes I felt pretty
bad it's like you know whenever you're
like barely started middle school I'm
like you think all the cool kids are
your friends but they're actually
secretly making fun of you I was the fat
kid that day ok but who is this
uncomfortable looking guy in the image
it's actually actor and comedian Andy
Samberg playing a character called shy
Ronny the ha ha image originates from
the second of two skits he did as the
character both of which featured Rihanna
the gag is that Ronny is so shy around
Rihanna that he's just hella awkward
unable to complete a rap verse or really
do anything besides mumble
[Music]
you can tell me nothing or laugh
awkwardly also for some reason a lot of
people oddly think that the picture is
of League of Legends Pro bjergsen a
bizarre theory that can perhaps be
traced back to this copypasta so the
basic theory behind cringe humor is that
the discomfort caused by the subject and
often their lack of awareness of it is
funny Michael are you Michael Scott oh
I'm sorry I'm I'm supposed to be meeting
someone named Michael oh that's not yeah
Michael Michael large hot chocolate with
caramel and shot government over the
past two decades this brand of humor has
really taken off with popular shows like
The Office Arrested Development and
Parks and Recreation embracing it to
varying degrees during the same period
the Internet has become inundated with
some of the creamiest content mankind
has ever produced hi baby girl
I just wanted to scream happy
seven-month anniversary babe
then the Li channel on jet sorry okay
guys are you ready
[Music]
why I don't know maybe it's the church
talk to the Pope he knows everything I
have it I'm gonna die
how can you die when you're dead whoa
hold on our 1g video wasn't that cringe
was it anyway haha is not without
controversy some twitch channels began
to ban the emote arguing that it was
used to describe everything a streamer
did even when it wasn't cringing you
guys stop cringing and everything please
I mean a lot of people are just gonna
have to stop watching the stream because
they got a stamp in space somewhere the
same old cranky face yes No everybody
vote oh the votes are coming in and it
looks like disabled cringe face is
winning Oh everyone's trying to spam
haha I'm getting timed out you oh my god
so many people are getting timed out
Jesus Christ in other words they felt
the emote was just being spammed to
insult and disrespect the streamer one
high-profile case of this was on the
stream for awesome games done quick in
2016 after the channel banned the use of
the word cringe viewers instead used
haha to criticize the speedrunners
taking part in the event the emote was
eventually banned from the games done
'quick channel in 2017 with the
justification being that the emo was
really only being used negatively of
course this just meant the viewers came
up with their own variations some
community members have even petitioned
to have the emote removed from better
twitch TV what's definitely true is that
if everything is cringe then nothing is
cringe can be funny cringe can be
painful
or cringe can be both at the same time
but it's defined by its deviation from
what we consider normal because I'm
going to go back to the Ministry and
allow them to proceed me as I am a
[__] goodbye
and if cringe is the new normal then
haha doesn't mean that much what I'm
trying to say is I think I ad lib to
shit-ton of that okay okay yeah B I
didn't say basically we saved basically
everything a lot in this grid we just we
I need to stop using the word basically
I don't think it's your fault
I want to blame oh my god the emote was
eventually banned from the games done
quick Channel in 2017 with the
justification that it was basically only
being used negatively basically I said
basically I'm like oh there was a big I
thought I added a basically